this is caller colion and anjonas koron
and two finnish national team badminton
players
we'll challenge them to a game of
badminton but we'll all play with
tailpins rockets
let's see who wins
we're
what
[Music]
i'm sorry
[Music]
[Music]
no pressure
[Music]
but there were no spin yeah
[Music]
maybe mikko we should now use our
special strategy
[Music]
all right so we've got a special move
that we've been secretly practicing
this one is the red dragon red dragon
pepper frog
[Music]
purple frog
good job we had our secret practice
[Music]
session
[Music]
red dragon we'll use the red dragon
[Music]
give me some directions where to go
[Music]
good
go
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
quite intense yeah
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
working well there
[Music]
good i got
[Music]
good
that was fun yeah actually really fun
and the level was actually quite good
yeah surprise surprise for the winners
city
what is it oh nice well you can put it
on
any table actually yeah exactly thank
you thank you for coming in then
challenge us yeah it was it was an honor
yeah it was fun really yeah we had a lot
of fun